Oh, no, it's an honor.
I can't believe
I'm someone's Make-A-Wish.
His name's Jason.
He's nine, he's gonna die,
like, yesterday.
Oh, my God.
You'll be fine.
( monitor beeping )
Hi, hi!
Hi, hi.
Hello.
Welcome.
He's, uh,
right over there.
Okay.
Hey, Jason, I'm Amy.
Um, I brought
this for you.
Oh...
Your headshot.
Okay.
Uh... I just want you
to know that you're--
you're really special
and, um...
and everything's
gonna be fine.
( monitor beeping )
Well, I'm realizing
that I bit off
a little bit more
than I could chew.
It was an honor
meeting you.
Oh, whoa, where-- where
do you think you're going?
I was gonna go
get my car.
Don't you know
why you're here?
I thought I was
just supposed
to come
and meet-- meet Jason.
Did I do something
wrong?
Roast me.
Roast you?
It was our son's
last wish
to be roasted by
a professional comedian.
Okay.
Yeah, I don't feel
comfortable
making fun of your son.
You think I give
a bitch queef
what you are
comfortable with?!
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Um...
Nice bed--
Why don't you get some more
tubes in your nose, weirdo?
( nervously chuckling )
Is that even a joke?
Okay, uh...
Where's the rest
of your hair?
Is it, uh,
at the hair parade...
Oh, God.
.. where there's
no hair?
Enough with
the softballs, please.
Okay.
This is really hard.
Hey-hey, hey,
little man.
Hi.
How ya feelin'?
Terrible.
Well, at least you feel
the way you look.
( laughing )
Am I right,
am I right?
Nah, I'm just jokin',
I'm just jokin'.
You're dark and handsome.
If it's dark...
you're handsome.
( laughing )
Okay, I gotta go,
I gotta go.
( whispering )
That's good.
( laughing )
LOL.
( man )
Oh, he's good.
Amy, take notes.
Those-- those were
hack one-liners
from the Internet.
What?
The Internet.
You know, the thing you
won't be on in three weeks.
Wow, Amy.
Hey.
That's not the direction
we're going in?
No.
Listen...
He's ready for a laugh
but, y'know, could you
please make sure it's funny?
Yeah, put some kind of
twist on it.
Has he been there
the whole time?
( woman )
Knock, knock.
( Jason )
Lisa Lampanelli!
My first choice.
It would either be me
or the Grim Reaper.
( laughing )
That's good.
We heard that you booked
a Toyota commercial.
You weren't
available, I...
Well, that explains
why Amy Schumer's here.
The girl's a miracle worker
with her comedy.
If she's funny,
it's a miracle.
( all laughing )
( man )
That's terrific.
Beat it!
( man )
Yeah, beat it.
Hey, wait a minute.
Who's dying here
first?
This guy...
or this guy?
( all laughing )
( woman )
Excuse me.
Are you Amy Schumer?
Yeah.
You have HPV.
We've been trying to
reach you for seven years.